[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to another day
of game sports play for all charity
streams I'm very excited for today we're
gonna have a nice chill stream joining
me is our reviews editor kelly plaguey
oh and special guest Joe Zee's you are
the voice of Claud from Fire Emblem
three houses and many many more voices
seriously an IMDB list to be envied and
proud of Joe thank you so much for
joining us thanks for having me I'm
really excited to be here so we are
gonna do something a little bit
different we are gonna be well I'll be
playing fly emblem three houses as you
can see from the switch that we got
ready first of all the ring for
adventure is a complete lie I don't even
remember the last time I played that
don't know why it's showing up but we'd
be playing Fire Emblem it's my say for
about 15 hours in but at the same time
yesterday Joe put out a call for well
Joe do you want to explain the segment
and explain what we'll be doing sure
yeah
so when we we we started streaming three
houses maybe last like September or
something like that we went through the
whole game and it was the first time I
had ever streamed I'm really not a
streamer that much at all and I kind of
wanted to make it into a show so I
thought we would have a halftime show
for any game that we played and I wanted
to make sure that it was something the
audience could participate in so we came
up with like a fake advice column like
Dear Abby as in the old Dear Abby column
a newspaper except it was de er like
with antlers and a B as in Eric mock so
it became a thing where at the halftime
every one of my fire emblem streams the
audience would submit questions like
life advice questions and so I put on
actually I think I have have him behind
me I put on a pair of derailleur and I
would answer their advice questions in
like probably the most absurd way like
it's not real life advice a couple of
times it was real I taught the entire
stream how to parallel park once and
people like that peaceful but yeah it's
usually just like a goofy segment we
have at the halftime I am very excited
so we put the call out yesterday and we
have a lot of responses people are asked
people have a lot of questions so I'm
gonna pull that up right now
great do you want to start off with one
or
play a little bit of the game and get
into it or let's uh let's start off with
one let's just okay let me put on the
appropriate paraphernalia so I'm
representing Black Eagles today and the
shirt I'm not usually wearing my typical
gold but we've got antlers so you know
you know it's it's a mash-up of all okay
are three houses there are three there
all look at that it's almost like we
planned it we did not uh this one really
need to read it aloud oh yeah go for it
I don't see where they're displayed so
so I'm going for the ones in reply to
your tweet so yeah threw them in order I
can as you will okay so first one from
at neo and double-oh-seven Dear Abby I
recently ordered some specially made
mittens for my hoops but something felt
off once I put the first one on in a
panic I snatched the mitten off only to
discover that my hoof was no longer
there but instead I now had a metal
wrench in place of my house
please help okay neo you've you really
got to pay better attention to the
Amazon description you've ordered magic
mittens magic mittens they're rare and
I'm surprised you to notice they're
usually more expensive but they will
change your appendages into various
things the best thing you can do is just
repeatedly put on the mittens and take
them off again cycle through different
appendages maybe you'll get something
you really like if you always wanted
like a peg leg if you were going for a
pirate theme or same in the pirate vein
if you wanted a hook as a limb just keep
going through them until you get your
hooves back it may take between one and
eight thousand tries you'll get there
okay good luck I think that's very sage
advice and also always be wary of Amazon
listen though I think Amazon I love I
love reading Amazon reviews of things
but especially I always order them by
the worst especially when things are
like five-star across the board and then
you order from across the west and it's
usually people who are like I didn't
know how to set this up so I'm just
giving it oh yeah like not packaging had
a broken corner or whatever
one stuff so should we get into the game
let's do it
like I said oh boy
base of operations my clouds I am
playing golden deer I'm 50 and a half
hours in so you guys are gonna
definitely have to guide me through me
that I like I know how to play this game
I was still being destroyed by maps but
I'd like just menu navigation was
obliterating me at the end of the game
but my chat that make fun of me for all
that stuff that is where I come in this
day we got calluses I also wanted to
draw everyone's attention to the
donation links which you can see just
below well below the game we do have one
donations I want to read really quickly
it's that way there we go I don't know
yes I oh yes mirroring is hard but we do
have where we're collecting donations
for both blacklivesmatter and for Direct
Relief for cover 19 we have one donation
here already from Evan hasten it's a
hundred dollar donation to black lives
matter thank you so much for your
donation and we're going to continue
reading them out you can make them
anonymous if you wouldn't want your name
read aloud and you can also leave
messages which we will read so thank you
in advance for being generous and we are
really excited to support these causes
you guys Rock thank you okay so I'm
gonna get it quick like glanced over my
my team Claude's doing well he's he's
gonna be I don't know like an archer
like a mounted Archer Lorenz I'm still
I'm still in the I don't know if I like
Lawrence yet
now you can scrap Lawrence bench him he
it was like right off the bat I mean I
made on Lawrence all the time I grew to
really like him by the end of the game
yeah and I just honestly I just love to
hate on him and in particular his
haircut his haircuts
a mess and he also there's a scene where
you can yell at him for making the girls
uncomfortable yes very that's a very
cathartic so is gonna say I might keep
him around just for that I think that
Lawrence has already had like a
quarantine haircut Raphael doing well
he's he's my boy I love him so much so
you could tell that because everyone's
like D and B and C I just went through
the last thing I remember doing was like
going through and
honing in on what everyone wants to do
and so ignite for example is you know
he's my sniper boy he that's the only
thing I'm good
yep yep I'm Sathya doing well
Marianne of her my fav well no no he'll
does my fav I appreciate anyone who just
yells their own name in celebration and
that's Leone
very big GA vibes from persona 4 yep
even we even like kind of the hair thing
now that we're done hair this entire
strange but here are great hairstyles
layer of the stream we're just good to
her hair yeah Sylvain I'll stay very
well slain just got here I think onto my
squad and I finally managed to convince
she had to join me too
so yeah that's basically no strong
golden dreg that's almost exactly what
my setup was and I played I recruited
Sylvain are you playing female by lifts
or male by Allah I am Sylvain just kind
of like it was like yeah I'm n yeah go
for it
he's the one who you can you just have
to be female you just woke up to him
he's like yes that's it that's it that's
all you need to do so get the DLC where
you can change her outfit because that
was a big priority for me you do that
her you do it now you did it you go back
to your room and you can change your
clothes there it's my room
also I'm very like I'm one of those
people who gets buttons wrong especially
because if I've been going between Xbox
Playstation and now switch and so a and
B has got me all kinds of messed oh yeah
eternal struggle yeah I think if you go
to the journal I think you can I think
you do it there oh my god unit
appearance this your first playthrough
Lussier is this a New Game+ now this is
my first playthrough oh that's exciting
yeah that's why I need you guys to help
me doesn't look like you have all the
extras but I do have a dancer ensemble
that okay did you make your dancer I
don't know how I have you can't do that
I know how did you do that I don't know
I really yeah
I'm not even do everyone but like I
think I'm pretty much done for the day
okay your activity points
did you give people gifts and stuff to
make them happy you can teach them leave
I did
oh the I'm used to playing on the joy
Khan's and so I'm getting it a little
bit of drift which is yeah let's go call
it a day for today because this is in
the middle and we will start up again
tomorrow
is that just um synced okay I want to
know how you got this outfit I have no
idea honestly I wonder how I can get
that outfit in real life
hello to everyone yes we'll go to
partakers of the Susie's
Dale Murphy the chat says beat DLC on
third playthrough and with the new
people nice thanks
should we partake in some festivities
let's do it yeah let's do it
alright so Joe how did you get involved
in fly emblem when you did you have to
audition did you know exactly what the
game was yeah you know what I was just
uh I was just talking to not to make
this a really long story but I was
talking to will Roche who's a composer
he composed on on Mortal Kombat 11 and
we've been friends forever and I was
asking him how he got involved with the
franchise and he told me this like super
elaborate story about how he knew some
guy and then they were talking and they
had coffee and then like four years
later someone and it was a really
interesting story right and people
always asked me like well how did you
get ex role I was like well someone
handed me a script and I read it into a
microphone and then they picked me it's
like really how it goes it's like
there's no like there's no super
interesting story I read for uh I read
for a bunch of different characters I
had no idea what it was
I read for Claude I read free to do I
read for Dimitri and I might have either
read for Ferdinand or Sylvain I think I
read for four or five characters um and
I remember like when I was reading for
it I was like man I hope I booked a
mitri cuz I want to act insane like I
just wanna I want to lose him
is it was it was really in his ark was
really interested in it and what they
presented in the audition sighs but yeah
then they then they called me I don't
know it maybe like a month later and
they were like hey you booked something
in this game which was codenamed so I
still didn't really know what it was and
I was like what was it and they're like
oh you put clot I'm like oh that's cool
I don't know what this is but so like it
really it took like maybe even after the
first couple sessions I wasn't really
clear on like how big of an impact the
game would have it wasn't until maybe
like four months before release when I
started seeing all like the conversation
surrounding the game and that I was like
ho okay this is a this is a big deal
this is this is gonna be fun what do I
do
yeah that's that's the origin story
that's what how do you approach I'm
gonna start the mission yeah but like
how do you approach you know you don't
really know the context I guess of the
role that you're auditioning for like if
stuff's got code names how much
information did they give you the
audition to kind of help you find that
voice less than a page it was um I
believe they had the character image
they basically told me like there's
going to be what we're calling a war
phase and an academy phase and there
will be a personality shift that occurs
between these two here are some Academy
phase lines here are some some war phase
lines we estimate on a scale of one to
five plods personality change will be
about it - as opposed to Demetri who was
a five out of five gotcha
and so that's pretty much all the
information I had there wasn't really
like any information unlike in being an
outsider or like where he was really
from and stuff like that it was just
sort of like his his attitude was
described and then he just kind of had
to go with it we have we are presented
with a choice how how do we want to
think just a hat yeah I'm one of those
people who every time I get the chance
to pick dialogue options I am always
very Paragon I to use the matter of fact
there you go phraseology like I am
always very nice to everyone because I'm
afraid I think that just speaks to me as
a person I'm always terrified of
upsetting people
yes oh the first game the first
playthrough always very nice second
playthrough [ __ ] I usually do that most
games I think the only exception was
Knights of the Old Republic I was
dealing from choice number one on both
of those force electricity or Force
Lightning yeah yeah okay
I missed that game it was this game - I
haven't played it in a while
I switched to a switch light and I'm
worried about the text bidding smaller
on my little yeah I haven't tried it I'm
I'm sure it's fine but I know that
there's a lot going on on the screen at
all times and you have to be really
conscious of what's happening especially
like the grid system like moving like
any strategy RPG mm-hmm
I never played it on handheld I always
put it on screen really I am just a
handheld player I just prefer that I'm
also kind of nearsighted so I find like
the closeness of I mean it's probably
why I'm nearsighted honestly because I
played so much game boys and kids but
have you Jo seen the fan er
for this game by the way oh my god I
used to feature a different fan artist
every stream because people would always
send me the most beautiful stuff
incredible there were some really really
excellent one of my favorite Ruby arts
are ubi underscore arts on on Twitter
they were taking Claude because Claude
has a lot of different like Middle
Eastern coding and Turkish references in
his lore in his clothing they would make
these beautiful pieces of art with like
flawed with like you know in Middle
Eastern
excuse me just like Middle Eastern
archways and stuff and like script
behind him there's so much amazing art I
I can't draw a straight line so I like
I'd I just blow it blows me away
someone's someone shot out a picture of
Idul guard with a crown of thorns on it
yesterday
and it was just like oh I saw those so
good like what a powerful what a
powerful powerful image yeah for a very
complex character I love it I love I
love what artists do they they excite me
very much okay absolutely
checking out everyone we're in a good
spot although my my honor is on the line
um but you guys gonna help me out
are you playing this is what are you
playing easy are you playing cuz I am
NOT I don't trust myself I played I
played casual and normal I just like
there for me because I knew I was gonna
stream the game there didn't seem to be
a lot of entertainment value in like
constantly soft resetting the game so
that I like if I'm gonna do that anyway
I might as well just you know just play
casual because like that with good
intentions that like if I play an ex-con
yeah I'm gonna play on on iron man I'm
gonna play so that I lose and like
actually get build these attachments to
the characters and then I lose them and
it'll be my fault but then you lose the
first one typically very early on and
then I will restart and go no yeah and
that's just like oh you're gonna restart
anyway yeah well I do think that the
rewind mechanic in this game is so smart
because it prevents you from having to
soft reset you can just rewind your
actions and I think it it really
underscores how complex and deep the
strategy is because there were so many
times where like I would rewind because
I played on classic and hard so I would
have to rewind a lot and even just one
movement would change the whole you know
the the course of the battle and I
thought that was really interesting
I love that so much about this game so
you're in the battle the Eagle online
this is this is great so like the Battle
of the weird foreshadow it's basically
shadowing I'm nervous like I've played
like a lot of things on stream before
usually first-person shooters
puzzle games nice little Diablo has
things never strategy and so now I'm
afraid that you don't see how much how
my brain works so I'm gonna network
we've got you don't worry your your
endear so you're gonna start out in the
bottom right I think no you started it
in the top as it must change depending
yeah like you start out in the top as
blue lions - okay how do we want to
approach this so from what I remember I
don't remember what the field looks like
but I remember I basically mop the floor
with the blue lions before I even
remotely paid attention in the black
eagles but I can't see what is going on
here um you like that's what I did I
think I dealt with adel guard laughs yes
oh god is treasure chest up here I think
I'm gonna disregard that for a while
though okay so edelgard is always like
that's her spot she loves it yeah that
was our area yeah
so I'm afraid that if I let's go let's
go for blue lines like they've got this
little kind of contingent over here with
ash so like let's bring some people
here's my secret
I'm just gonna wait can i yeah let's
have you wait here I'm trying to think
like Sofia and Mariana keep back well
yeah just make sure you wish ease don't
don't start becoming frontline fighters
you can yeah you know you can tap I
think it's one of the Z buttons to show
like the danger zone of where you can
get attacked and can't get it oh here we
go yeah so anything anything that's not
purple no one can hit them next turn you
stay back here okay right the range of
movement here so I'm gonna have you know
you're still pretty squishy so let's do
that
what's the Lawrence Lawrence is wants to
become a boy do you unit yeah he's
getting everything okay my boy the dodgy
I could um where is oh he's over here
okay sylvain let's slowly but gradually
move you over why he started literally
as far away as possible from where I
needed you to be um I'd like you being
front line see this is the thing like
there's so many of them I got to move
everyone pretty much individually
[Music]
alright I'm gonna ask you some advice on
Hilda let's move you up front that you
can't move that far oh that was my
favorite murderess throughout I mean I
melt through enemy lines and she would
take no damage she would dodge
everything my team by the time I had to
endgame I think
I don't remember I'm looking at my chat
do you guys remember did I do the last
battle in one turn did I have one shot
anyway I think I won shuttle I think I
one shot at a ttle guard in the
second-to-last battle
it was either with Claude because at
that point Claude could move pretty much
anywhere on the map yeah and yeah I
don't I don't remember see I I love ya
like I love staying back and just like
taking people out very very graduating
yep
[Music]
telling me I did indeed one shot
edelgard and do that in one turn that's
incredible not the last battle you can't
do the last battle I forgot how
complicated that that last thing is we
have a $10 donation from Matt Hawking to
direct release the messenger message is
love Claude Joe did an excellent job
playing the subtleties of his character
golden deer was my first house and first
in my heart but that dubstep battle
music I don't know dubstep missiles
thanks for the donation
all right Sylvain let's go boy
I love Silvana I so my first house was
blue lions and I chose that because we
were trying to make sure that because we
got the game early for work right and
we're trying to make sure that we had at
least one person who was playing the
game play each house so we could
properly cover the game and so I I knew
that some people were really interested
in Black Eagles because of edelgard so I
was like okay all I'll try a blue lions
and so I did become very attached to
them and I love Sylvain and when I did
my Black Eagles around I recruited him
like right away because I was like I
need him to be on a wyvern ASAP yeah I
love Y for fighters how do I end my turn
if you're not gonna do anything with
Marianne oh I can just shift it up there
in the behind the grass let's just wait
there there you go I'm just slowly like
moving
everyone up that's good you could take
your time so how do we want to do this
do we want to go all the way up the left
and then like kind of circle around or
do you want to just take out at all by
the time you get up there on the left is
a good chance that you're gonna have a
bunch of black eagles in your face
anyway
but I don't think it's gonna be a
problem yeah
Oh big black numbers got my friend more
to play three houses and she went with
Claude because their names run there you
go that's a good race that's a great
modern Claude what's your take on the
there's an item you can find kind of
later on that's like a vial of poison
and it belongs to Claude and Claude has
this like he's got kind of some secrets
I find his character really interesting
even though he doesn't go completely
insane like Dimitri does you have a
meeting on the poison I always kind of
so it's probably I mean like now I'm not
Claude I'm just thinking in his head
it's probably not lethal poison it's
probably like a poison that will make
people break out in a rash or something
I kind of clawed a lot it's like a
harmless prankster like a you know
absolutely it's not I mean it's not like
totally harmless I think at one point he
does suggest giving everybody the
stomach flu in order to make a battle
easier and like he's ready to do it he's
a schemer you know like he's he's very
much going on he's running he's like
he's like the Odysseus of of the game
where like he really always wants a
chance to display his cleverness
sometimes maybe to the detriment of
what's going on and that's that's a very
dision kind of attitude mmm wait hold
Lawrence there and get him healed up but
I need to use the there's a heal where
there's like you don't have you do if
you're just in the adjacent square then
it doesn't like take up too much and
like a a unit cost I think everybody
you mean like he'll versus physic yes
it's physic you can do like over long
distances yeah those all right hardest
part is getting over this bridge because
it's like such a bottleneck but once you
get through it doesn't even look like
you it just looks like you could just
wait over it I'm just yeah I know like
come on guys just leave your feet white
but then but then you know who knows how
heavy those boots are gonna be yes right
right people on the horses I mean weird
that River you guys they didn't like
teach that it's a military school Oh
Kimmy boy says you should send Ignatz or
close to the central Hill come on that
yeah on it right now is it Brando um we
have another donation for black lives
matter from Ryan Obermeyer for ten
dollars thank you so much Ryan for your
donation thank you all right oh I forgot
that I have like notifications 10 on my
Lex and when stuff gets delivered it
pings and it terrifies me every single
time so that's what that was haha good
news there my keyboard arrived good no
more RSI for me good luck gamer deboard
well yeah the mechanical keyboard it's
softer it's a razor it's not like the
fully mechanical one because part of me
thinks that would be really satisfying
but then part of me wonders if I would
get annoyed by it I find it very
satisfying I have I've had one for like
a year and a half that's just that's
yeah sounds like popcorn great yeah oh
that's weird
across the bridge there
yeah it's like a half-and-half partly
mechanical partly not just like softer
right hang on it but I'm just very
excited to not I basically have like a a
typist like a thing that you would find
in an office but it's really terrible
total gaming so this bridge all right
[Music]
wait term says you should send wave
after wave of my own men
very good hahaha where's net Burnie on
the ballista I can't help it I love her
so much
Oh coming in from behind yeah just just
watch your your little yeah I should set
up the snipers there yeah but just drop
him with archers he'll go down fast Oh
Raven says LexA thea is a monster she
shreds everyone yes she does oh yeah we
told her our tactical nuke yeah who's go
isn't like yeah it's foods there move
you back what's it like playing game
where you are that you're in you know
like we're talking about this actually
before the stream the initial the
initial shock is interesting like it's
like it kind of kicks you out for a
second but afterwards like after playing
it for a long time because this is a
long game is another game I've been
playing for a long time called shadow
versus like we're playing it a bunch I
stopped hearing myself like I stopped I
just are hearing like Rowan or clot or
whatever
and it wears off after a while you know
I've done I've done a bunch of games so
the the shock factor isn't quite what it
used to be yeah I remember when I was
fox mccloud for Star Fox zero the battle
begins that was like my first big role I
think I booked it like four months after
I moved to LA and like someone that when
I saw that I straight-up cry like it was
like I was like holy crap that's my
voice coming out of fox mccloud mouth so
uh yeah you know like all things it kind
of it kind of wears off with time but
there's there's never a day where I
don't wake up and go like is this real
this my life like is this what I do for
a living so yeah but after a while it
just starts to sound like plot in my
head sounds like a different person to
me yeah so how did you get into voice
acting
I started in corporate work which I
actually still do a fair amount of
because it's it's a good business
practice yeah I started I wasn't here I
was in Virginia the real origin story is
is weird I make the joke that oh I got
into voiceover pretty much like
everybody did which was I was a military
intelligence officer for the United
States Air Force and then left the Air
Force to work in similar capacities for
the government suddenly discovered
voiceover one day and then quit my job
sixteen months later Wow really not not
now your typical origin story there was
a weird it was a really weird like life
shift I was um I was on duty as a
reservist I left active duty and I was
on a weekend there's nobody else in the
office and I was on google chat with a
friend of mine we're just talking about
whatever and I was like yeah I've always
kind of wanted to try voice acting and
he's like well my company used to hire
talent for like our corporate marketing
stuff from this website once you go
check it out so I did I booked the first
thing I auditioned for and I was like
wow that was cool and then eight months
later I sat down with my employer and I
was like I I'm working 16-hour days
doing both of these things and frankly I
like the other thing better I can either
quit or we can go half time what would
you like to do and he's like we'll we'll
make a part-time position for you and
we'll let you phase out which was super
gracious and so eight months after that
I quit my job and then move to LA to
hunt because you really can't do a whole
lot of character work and you're not in
LA yeah that's what I really wanted to
do so I moved to LA in 2015 origin story
that's that is quite the story it's a
little odd it's been a weird life I
almost find that with games though I
think there's an you know kind of gaming
adjacent industries it's like people
never really think of it as a career
path okay I know Kylie and I get asked
quite a lot it's like how did you start
working in games and at least for me
it's you know when I was younger I
wanted to work in I wanted to be an
archaeologist for a while then I wanted
to work in psychology and criminology
for a while and then it's you kind of
get to the phase where you're like oh
this is a thing that I can do and then
you just fall into it and it's a weird
really like great industry than everyone
like if you get the chance if you want
to work towards something it's awesome
yeah the universe tends to like open up
itself every once in a while and you
just kind of have to flow with it that's
that's what I feel like I've I've
learned in my life I've taken many many
unexpected turns and just got to go with
it yeah and in the cool thing about the
this industry too is that there isn't
like one straight path to do it so you
do meet a lot of people who have all
these interesting backgrounds and have
series do I mean we have a co-worker
Michael who used to do political
consulting you know like just stuff that
you wouldn't think is related but they
are experiences that lead you to this
and it's I think the way it informs how
you do your job in the gaming industry
is always really interesting I started I
started college as a chemistry major so
I completely just was like new and did a
hard hard right on that one also like
what
before I do donations let's consult here
on this move oh I was gonna say do you
want to do a Dear Abby oh about Gregg
Chung well there's always one about Greg
Greg's always become more of an icon in
my streams than I have so this is from
Gebhardt attack oh yeah I know get heart
attack Dear Abby if you and Greg Chan
were to anthropomorphise
anthropomorphised water creatures
battling in the underground of a
dictators palace who would win the thing
I love about that question is how
specific it is Pacific and I'm trying to
think it like a reference in a
particular video game we're like I don't
know like is this about ecco the dolphin
like of the Sega game so if okay so if
we were both anthropomorphised water
creatures fighting a dictator no you do
I'll claim each other in the underground
of a dictators palace okay so I think I
think probably what would happen here is
Greg and I would battle like like like a
Dragon Ball Z battle right with super
super like bombastic and things just
blowing up and eventually we'd end up
kind of like fallen on our backs doing
like the anime breathing where neither
of us can get up right yeah that's how I
see this happening and then at one point
we would look at each other and be like
you want to go kill the dictator and
he'd be like yeah and then we go do that
so it'd probably end in a draw followed
by the complete dissolution of a
tyrannical monarchy that's probably how
I see I like it of that you love to see
it
Kathy please help me I was gonna take on
so I was gonna take my arches in and
take out these boys is that good yes
come out yeah you don't need to get
right up to him though you can fire away
yeah I think Agnes has a larger
wait why are you doing they probably
have to
so I've quit guys here and clawed but
they are gonna move in order to fire so
maybe let's take out you don't have to
move them super close like you can move
them a little bit to the left probably
or to the down to the down down yeah
like don't put them right next to the
pega pega sighs I'm just trying to get
them to hit from that I think I'm moving
right now yeah you have to move they
have to move the shoe because I think
they only have a two range right I'm a
little bit like not next to it so like
square away like you and try yeah and
then try to work okay yeah should yeah
should just take it out do we want to
use a combat whoa don't he just he's got
this hard now ignite should be able to
do the rests thanks [ __ ] no how could
his weapon is but he knows what's good
for our nation yeah oh yeah he's despite
being kind of a little bit weedy he is
my most powerful he's so good night with
another quarantine echo I'm gonna set
these three mmm kind of want someone
watching the rear so I'm gonna leave
these is there anybody coming those were
the last people approaching well this
guy was here and then he kind of like
went back so I'm just gonna leave a
little bit just to see how we go on this
is dicey cuz you yeah you know this is
where I'm gonna get in trouble so
probably good but you could also bait
them if you put
sylvain and probably bile if in the
bushes well they're evasive miss will at
least go up me move him not to the left
probably more so he's not attracting all
of them
yeah like that right that one hair just
wait yeah the agent goes up in the
bushes and vilest should be able to take
two hits if I'm honest I mean is like
you have flame as your forget what it's
called when you attach a character I
think flame is attached to use a flame
should be healing you too sometimes do I
have oh it's decent ash not yeah she's
she's like just attached to bile if
basically um what about the what about
this whole little gang Lawrence we've
got like Cynthia
we've got Raphael and Leonie could
probably move start moving them towards
the Bullis I like to draw the enemies
towards me to kind of separate them
that's my strategy in this in this
specific battlefield
so like that yeah yeah so you if you put
them next to each other I'm gonna get
him healed up again though because he's
he's taking some hits huh
[Music]
nothing I think that's the thing that I
really like about fire movies like the
constant feeling of progression and I
just love I think how you said it best
in your review and you're just like I
love watching those numbers go up
seriously it is constant positive
reinforcement after after we see how
this turn goes I'll read some donations
but yeah sweet Oh Joe I go back and play
Final Fantasy games like every five
years or so I just replayed Final
Fantasy Tactics and it was just like
like what a like it's a great game but
playing it in contrast to how far
strategy games have come and like how
smooth it is yeah like if I could badly
describe Final Fantasy Tactics it's like
30 hours of leveling up by using potions
on yourself like that's like that's how
it became played out because you
wouldn't you don't get any experience
from getting hit or moving or anything
like your character has to take an
action and a lot of times your character
can take no action yeah so like you just
have to throw potions on yourself the
whole time and you're hitting you're
hitting your own teammates just a grind
so it doesn't hold like the gameplay
doesn't hold up as well but especially
like right after playing yeah s RPG I
see someone's point from behind
okay good she's distracting I'm good in
grid 2 oh good all right then we're
gonna die cuz this is a mock battle but
rip forgot God - oh great
outfit battle dancer it's very being
answered but still holding like a sword
and shield great she did a good amount
of damage yeah you do have flame
attached which is good to get flame some
level - if you want to end up using her
okay we did get a few things another
donation from Ryan Obermeyer this time
for direct relief $10 and says a happy
that I get to help people and watch Fire
Emblem hope you all are having a great
day thanks Ryan Ryan and then we have
another one for direct relief from
acer's then
for $15 they say hi Cali Lucy and Joe
thank you for all your hard work and
support over these difficult times Joe's
a hilarious nerd and voices some awesome
characters and hosts an amazing
community
Lucy try pulling at a princess cannon
and I'll obliterate the whole
battlefield wait wrong game fear the
deer thanks hey sir here's one of my
suppose they've been my audience for a
long time then I'm going over to the
black lives matter feed we got one from
Chris McCarthy for $10 thank you so much
Chris we have on from I'm very sorry if
I put your your name nawaz eat ball for
$10 and then from Akio Lin for $7 thank
you all so much for your donations to
black lives matter thank you guys
Aki's and a great it's really nice to
see like faces and like repeat names and
people in the chat a lot yeah yeah thank
you Joe for bringing in your good
community what Joe no just help me help
me fine you'll be fine so um do you have
are you in range to heal from yeah you
can I've got physic if you could
physically Sylvain she's not gonna be
targeted from there which is good oh
wait did I mess that up uh she couldn't
move him back and have her move forward
do that cuz I would like her piloff is
doing just fine I was doing right oh
yeah you can just do heal which is there
you go all right I mean if we take out
this lad you think we're still in range
of Benny though but I would prefer to
take him out so let
we could orient yourself around to his
left like if you move Raphael
yeah like if you move more to the left
you're not as in range of Bernie
although I guess didn't really change
but wait can he go here and still attack
I don't know if you can I think he has
to be Raphael's have pretty good bullet
sponge too you can heat it oh you have a
combat art yeah he could take oh I don't
need it right now so it's let's just
shift him hang and then yeah what do we
got oh yeah Samba day oh boy what a
crits are so satisfying to watch they
really are okay so how you can this is
where it's who's on the horse there's at
Lawrence Lawrence Leone
yeah he only move him towards the kind
of the cluster yeah my god at the very
least other than the one that's got it
yeah I'm pointing to get it like you can
see what I'm pointing at but yeah there
now you have any any combat Arts or
battalions battalion stuff you can use
battalions yet a little like if a gambit
I've got roster I grant banette monsters
gambit I've got you definitely take back
that
yeah Gander up heavy yeah well I think
is if your gambit could stun those
enemies then that's probably a good I
would hit all of them I would do the
gambit yes Orion effect gambit yeah it's
all troop yeah do that one you were yeah
I would do that
then I think you can stun them so they
won't be able to move I think that's
what assault troopers I think if it
doesn't kill him it will I don't know if
it's what grounded but I think it's dead
anyway yeah he's out
oh good flings there you go
nice nice okay so what do you want you
could have he'll to take that one out
easily I think make sure you keep her in
range
I can't reach oh okay to get that one
yeah yes there's some there's some kill
to action yeah we had a big like anytime
that she had a big hit we had the
graphics playing of killed on this Lucy
I would yeah let's check up on the
you're kind of like B team in the back
your sniper team nobody's coming their
way it would be a good idea I was on the
B team is that how we're going here that
I misspoke the the the special teams of
I would move I would start moving on the
board yeah I would start moving them
across that bridge now because I don't
think you have anyone coming on your six
really let's do another Dear Abby - yep
[Music]
already just Lin for one three Dear Abby
I wish to open a store to provide salt
for my fellow dear what would be a good
name for the store well salt & straw is
already I think trademarked and
copyrighted they're an ice cream store
and they're delicious so hmm that's an
interesting one salt salty dere's like
salty dogs but a let's see
lots of the earth oh well the earth is
good
how about assault troops you could just
go with the gambit assault troops is
good hmm I like salted the earth though
also the earth I think is the winner
here since you I'm assuming that you're
gonna stock salt licks you could you
could get racy and just call it lick
this because like this and people will
be like you know that'll bring customers
in there maybe you don't want that those
customers so that stuff if you're
rolling Stolte licks or Neelix is good
[Music]
well you are honestly yeah there's lots
of options you can hit make it like a
half salt and half guitar store you
could call it like amazing licks like
it's Harlan and with special team alpha
anyone has any objections I don't like
how he's we snuck in Oh like how he's
big they do it from across the river is
that good or is that bad because it
could it'll be harder for him to get to
Ignatz then it'll take me longer there
but then Claude go from there to there
not I mean
I just did we determine whether or not
horses can cross the river or they air
to water there's a scared of water so
there's really not gonna come behind you
but it's just I mean how is it ignites
more powerful without a combat r8 it's
because the combat arts sometimes take
advantage of the weapons triangle in in
some respect which is its kind of been
retired in this game like the previous
fire games rely more on not rock paper
scissors but the combat arts are kind of
the way they retain that that's or to
boost your range for sacrificing on that
bar exactly
closed I'm just gonna go for a regular
he can take him I would have loved to
create that but you know yeah well Joe
like looking back and all the characters
that you voiced like which has been the
one that's really like not only the one
that's resonated the most with like the
audience but like which of you really
enjoyed voicing the most well I mean
Claud is undoubtedly the most popular I
really enjoyed we're actually we're
playing through it right now on stream I
played this character his name is say
sorry and just cause for today's our is
he's like a crazy alien conspiracy
theorist still like I got to just act
insane
and then we also did full mocap for that
game so that was like a really great
experience yeah I'm on the volume with
everybody and like it was really it was
a really awesome experience and the day
we rapped was like it was like a rough
day because I knew I wasn't gonna get to
hang out with anybody again
so like that experienced on the whole
was really really great
um I don't know there's like you know
it's hard to say I didn't have fun at
any of these these jobs anytime I get to
act like a villain is a lot of fun being
crazy it's fun
I'm in I'm in a Nickelodeon series right
now called LEGO City adventures oh we're
on
I think we're halfway
like season 2 on Nick it comes on here
right before right after sponged why I
can't remember but I play one of the
main characters Duke detain and a fire a
fireman named Clemens and those sessions
have been probably the most fun I've had
in voiceover because it's ensemble cast
and a traditional animation setting so
like I'm sitting in the room with eight
other people were way better than me so
like like I'm just I'm sitting in a room
and like I've got Roger Craig Smith in
there I've got Eric Allen back in there
troy baker and nolan north has stopped
by a couple of times
Fred's hat ashore has been in there the
voice of dexter from dexters lab the
voice of Johnny Bravo it's just like
we're all in there and I'm sitting there
in and I'm so I get to absorb their
awesomeness for like four hours
and we laugh our asses off like we have
such a good time probably like my
biggest upset of quarantine is not being
able to do those sessions anymore
because they were so so fun yeah I love
love love love working on that on that
show awesome that's like a an animation
Greatest Hits - it sounds like a glass
is wild like III every time I'm in there
I'm like am I in the right room like did
you guys are you looking for someone
else named Joey I know it's a common
name okay so but like you belong there
right like you you have a like Lucy said
you have an IMDB list to be envy deaths
I guess a lot of times like I feel like
I'm still I've only I haven't even been
in LA for five years yet so like I still
feel pretty new um and these guys have
doing it like these guys have been doing
stuff 20 some of them 30 years have been
in animation like you know games I was
playing when I was in high school I'm in
the room with the people who were
voicing them so it's uh yeah it's it's a
pretty interesting feeling awesome it
can be really humbling - it is and it's
great I I'm if you're I always say if
you're the smartest person in the room
you're in the wrong room you're not
learning anything I love being a dumbest
guy in the room that's a good way of
looking at it it kind of flipping
stur syndrome onset it's like no I'm
just here to learn you doin Lucy I'm
doing okay
I took a turn that see I've kind of got
rid of a bunch of people freed up my
lads
some on the chat says she's definitely
play this game for I have I just haven't
touched it in a few months and it's like
getting to grips with everything again
hey it's fine honestly we were playing
portal yesterday and that is a game that
I absolutely have not played since 2011
and that was yeah it's fantastic but
it's like Jesus Christ there's a lot to
forget about portal 2 because of all
like the new gameplay mechanics and
stuff on that okay it's crazy it's been
like 10 years since I played that game
that's crazy
dang um right now what types of
characters do you look forward to diving
into but haven't had the opportunity yet
oh geez um as far as types I played a
pretty good gamut of characters from
like scary crazy demons which I don't do
very often like that's not my voice
print you shouldn't hire me to be an orc
I played works but in general go to JB
Blanc please like he's not gonna ruin
his voice and he's gonna be way better
at it than I am
as far as like types of characters I
really want to play I would love to play
badass like I haven't really played a
real badass yet I'm only thinking of
Just Cause because we were streaming it
but like some of the cool stuff that
like Orion acabo who played Rico got to
do just like superhero landings and like
look just looking straight in the camera
like you like I don't I don't get to
play a whole lot of badass I'm just I
don't give off the badass vibes I get
off I give off like the young plucky
hero vibes man I'd love to play it I'd
love to play a real badass someday
that's that's a character that I think
I'd like to play you think you see
things about voice prints like how do
you how do you like sort of identify
what your niche is and like what your
skill set is as their training that you
can do are their voices I go who the
other people in the voice acting
community who you look up to
and kind of want to be sort of like
known as you know a contemporary of so
um as far as like discovering one's
voiceprint for me it was just brute
force I mean the corporate the corporate
career like all the the e-learning and
web stuff and and the boring unsexy
stuff that I do I've done a whole lot of
it so after a while you kind of like
auditioned for absolutely everything and
you start seeing what you get picked for
um and the same thing with video games
like you know any agency any good agency
is gonna send you pretty much everything
at the beginning and then start seeing
what stick what sticks so every once
awhile yeah I'll book a book so whatever
in it but it's not it's not very often
it and it can be very uncomfortable so
you learn like what feels good and you
just kind of go for it as far as like
you know and people who I look up to
Troian own are both exceptional actors
and they kind of sit
they sit where I am
Matt Mercer is well we kind of all sit
in a similar spot and it's I was
actually in a I was in a lego session
and I had to no one wasn't there but we
were in a scene that had him and the
director was like Joe can you read in
for no one's role and I did it and she
looks at me she's like you sound exactly
just like you sound exactly like no one
and that happened like three times in a
row she's like I cannot believe how much
like him you sound so like you know you
and then once you kind of understand
that feeling you look at some of the
other roles that like he has done or
other people of Don you're like okay can
I can i mimic that can I can I can I
step into those shoes a lot of finding
different character voices and finding
different ways to act for me has always
been about emulating other people and
then putting my own spin on it
dupe detain it's just a bad patrick
warburton impression like that's all it
is bad impressions are new characters so
yeah there's there's lots of ways to
kind of find find your voice home and
sometimes it comes around and some
really on
effective ways awesome
so from the chat Lauren Kelly says
Claude is a badass just saying that's a
I think I think maybe like superhero
badass that's what I'm talking about
like Bloods claw you know he's got some
badassery for sure you know I understand
the difference yeah I also want to read
aquiline also donated to direct relief
to leave a message another $10 donation
aquiline says oh shoot yeah we could
write messages thank you for doing this
guys we need people like you you three
in these days and I hope that the little
I give will help at least a bit much
love to you and then there's something
written in French that I will butcher
but it means fear the deer in French
nice it looks like Craig Nez let's surf
yes thank you again I'm gonna check the
matter donations just in case and I just
want to say that it is not little every
little bit counts so we really
appreciate any donation amount thank you
so much
it's funny in the UK there's a
supermarket called Tesco and oh yeah
that wine is every little helps and so
every time I say it I'm like not
secretly doing marketing for Tesco here
I just you know every loved us help they
really got the they really nailed that
tagline on Tesco okay so I'm feel like
I'm I'm back in the groove of it we did
lose Lysa Thea oh we missed it
I was on the stream I would that you
were answering Mecham it comes down hard
when you lose a character everyone got
really upset even though I was I'd be
like guys I'm on casual they're fine
they're just taking a knee somewhere
okay everyone's like just
resting it's fine so I think even on
even on classic I don't think you
actually lose anyone in this battle you
know it's all fake here so I imagine
with Foam swords nerf arrows yeah
paintball guns or whatever okay moving
on up so I moved here because there was
a guy I was trying to bait but then he
got baited by everyone else so that guy
needs to chill out okay oh god something
bad have this guy just I don't know
slowly making his way around his way
downtown battle fields is very empty did
everyone just kill each other and then
you swept up the remains yeah how did
you do that it took out a couple I know
but the ill guard side is like see there
all seem to be connected and like I
don't know uninterested in me so I'm
gonna go here yes
yeah it can happen yeah let's just go
you know why not lose our both house
leaders out I don't see ya I took out to
meet you think umm Adel God is Phillip
here so what we just sit there yeah we
could ignore all that make sure you just
go round
he's crater could get that chest too
just as a fun bonus yeah forget what in
there actually I left how many tests
locked and closed my chat got so mad I I
like people who goes for collections and
wants to get as much as I can but Fire
Emblem is the game I'm like I don't
trust myself to make that trip I will
look at the end of the game there were
several people in my in my community
that we're offering to manage my
inventory for me because I just wouldn't
do it
like it was just like this whole mess of
crap that like I didn't pay attention to
anymore
it's difficult oh he's a great question
[ __ ] talking with fire emblem in
particular did you find much of a
difference playing chord pre and post
I'm skip
Floyd's like I was talking about when I
was talking about auditioning for Claude
his his pre and post time skip I ideals
his character didn't change as much as
many folks so in some cases I had an
easier job but it also made it a more
difficult job because that shift had to
be very subtle but had to be also very
palpable so we worked hard on sort of
like Claude keeping his nonchalance
about even stuff like war but
understanding its impact and that's what
I tried to infuse for the war phase is
just like Claude like this is a it's the
outcome is real it's not you're not just
playing military games anymore but he
was still making the same kind of jokes
so that subtlety was actually really
difficult
Patrick sites who was the director on
the project really helped me a lot with
keeping that real a friend of so a
couple of my friends have messaged me
and they said the big fire movement my
friends is the problem with Claude is
that he makes IRL and seem so plain yeah
yeah the what do you that the real thing
is like he's got the chinstrap beard
which is a handicap right yeah I think
the chinstrap beard is just like he's
like I'm - I'm - gorgeous I got to put
this thing on my face to kind of tamper
it down a little bit like this is too
powerful please give him a chance grab
here so the the real trick to opening
all the chests is to recruit ash because
ash is he's a thief on top of whatever
class you give him so you can put on a
horse and then s/he can pick any lock we
can happen like run around the
battlefield to all the chests so I
didn't know that maybe I would open more
Asha's i found that now just because i
picked blue lines and i part of it was
because I thought Ash's ability was so
useful because that's just his thing as
he can pick he's a as the thief's
ability to pick locks but no always can
have him do any class you want there's a
not to go back to the chinstrap beard
but there's a great comic out there it's
like a to frame comic and it's or two or
three frame comic and it's claw it's
post time skipped clawed right and he's
wearing like a huge sombrero or
something like that right and by lift is
someone is I think it's viola it's like
Claude take that ridiculous thing off
and in the next frame you see him
peeling off his chinstrap beard sombrero
it's it's great excellent Shh okay all
right let's see this one no movement or
stun no action I can't move I can do an
action you can shoot the guy yeah let's
he will do very good heal yourself if
you have important what's my odds Oh cuz
these are heavies how's the house the
magic and it work is Nosferatu you gonna
do anything worthwhile
not that worthwhile so whenever I see
those brought to you I think of the
spongebob episode where he goes
Nosferatu and I like that's just all
like how my brain works worth using just
for that me let's take a chip chip a
little bit off oh he can only go for
that one because he's he's right next to
the other one who can't shoot from there
so can I guess Maryann probably can't
read Oh No
I've been done in here you know what
you're right ones dead I mean yet I
can't die it'll be fine believe oh I
can't take heat here cuz he's already
moved can we do
the only good again I don't know you
gonna be able to much damage with the
bulb sure it's gonna I'm just gonna move
them and you know pray yeah let's move
Raphael could actually do damage to them
well let's I'm just gonna try and lead
him on a merry chase I think um not a
bad idea they don't move very well okay
who hasn't gone tomorrow asks um Joe how
often do you think about that episode of
Friends where Joey tries to learn French
and keep saying je m'appelle Claude I
actually kind of totally forgot about it
until just now
but that's super applicable to my
community because one of my mods is
French and I'm always yelling on sin
setter it's not really French it just
sounds like French and Jim Appel Claude
wow that's really like that's really
apropos which is not French I think it's
Latin I'm very sorry for butchering the
French I just took Spanish I just can't
that's okay I don't know I don't know
how it works guys I don't know how we
survived that I think big nuts has one
health mean that he's gonna say my god
Oh
knock him out Oh oh my god okay our dear
that's right
uh okay please please do it he'll still
big here well that's a nice feel
okay feeling better about this let's do
another Dear Abby I've been loving these
questions sure like this one X Mirror
Mirror Dear Abby you're always answering
our questions and giving us dear advice
but I can't help but wonder if there are
any questions if there are any answers
or advice you need if you had to say
dear audience what question would follow
that's it that's that's quite the
curveball well when I ask the audience
let's see well dear audience why are you
following me like what well you guys you
guys gonna go out in the world and and
and find someone that's way cooler find
someone that's actually a badass you're
bad yeah why aren't like your dear dear
audience why are you so good to each
other what might one of the things about
my my audience that like blows my mind
is that they take care of each other so
much like we have a private discord for
it switch subscribers right and first of
all like I never created a single
channel in the discord everyone did it
themselves and it includes like a
Cooking Channel where people are sharing
family recipes and a homework channel
where people help each other with their
homework
how are you so wholesome like how how
how does this group of people exist that
is just so great to each other I mean
like yeah that's all I see in my discord
is people helping people and I just
don't understand how you're not worse
people that's all that's my it's my dear
audience question how are you not
crappier that's all I got that's great
and it like I think it speaks to you as
a person that you are bringing all these
people around you whether you know
intentionally or not therefore graduated
towards you and they're all spreading
that positivity among themselves maybe
where it speaks better than them
they're not corrupted by my awful
influence at just how strong they are
they can they can resist josie ji I
think there is really something to be
said for fostering a positive community
and I do think like yes I think a lot of
the credit goes to moderators and
community members but awesome yeah like
as somebody who tried to foster
communities like that in the past like a
lot of that'd be really difficult and
you know it's I think I've said stuff
was humbling before on the stream but it
is really come blink to see people be so
wholesome and great okay can we just one
away I can't open it wait Dwight okey
does anybody have a key oh how do i
what's the easiest way to check I didn't
say get on it let's look at the convoy
envoy I don't think I have a key you
know oh I do
okay let me okay
yes uh I will give that to Lawrence Tom
this convoy
can I give it trade you know just take
it can I give us a loan now trade we
made Lawrence good sweet L bit okay oh
you go nope
Oh Lawrence there go somewhere else it's
okay Nate I can't drift I was talking
about this earlier but my my joy cones
are screwed for lack of a better term
and my I think my pro controller is also
not doing so hot like it's a really
different drifting a little bit and I'm
not using that as an excuse chat but I'm
using it as it is like George is really
it's a pain first my experience that I
was trying to play Smash Brothers
against somebody and I'm like this my
rights joy Khan doesn't charge anymore
lame which makes what you call it ring
fit very difficult because it doesn't
track half of the movement and some
being shot at by the rink on glad you
saying I'm not doing everything like I'm
like doing push-ups like this um okay so
got a nice little heel going here Leila
guards all that's left right Oh God and
there's one problem
Hubert or Lynn right there's two lads
over here but they're not really doing
anything hanging out having a lovely
time I knew I knew those guys in
military school I know who they are
[Laughter]
like they just they don't want to get
involved right now they've seen how it's
gone down
I'm just gonna wait that they know that
we can't get over that because of the
bridge carnage has been immeasurable so
I'm just gonna turn to everyone to be I
guess in position and then we'll take
the battle to it'll gone sounds good
should we do another Dear Abby while we
prep
okay so PBR chase aka Zack Dear Abby I
seem to have taken you'll fear the deer
catchphrase too close to heart and I am
now terrified of these pointy headed
ungulates what great wood how can I
shake my newfound phobia of deer so now
your dear phobic you took fear the deer
too literally and now you have a case of
deer phobia totally natural happens all
the time
particularly if you hear deer in the
wild they have they make a very
terrifying noise that I think is
actually more it's scarier than like
bears
it's they just make a really hideous
noise so if you've got if you've got
deer phobia we were just talking to
someone that has recently set up a salt
shop so you go ahead and go to salt of
the earth and you buy some salt lake's
and you can hang those hang those in
your backyard and that you'll the deer
will come and you'll see that they're
generally very docile don't don't try to
approach or pet them
it could be carrying a Lyme disease but
I think that that would be a good way
for you to get over it get over the fear
of the deer now just to be clear you
should fear the deer but it may be
because of Lyme disease and not because
they're just because check yourself for
ticks okay everybody knows oh my
roommate is very afraid of ticks and as
a British person they are not really
considered a threat in the UK and that
really a thing there are anything at all
we went hiking once and Greg got kind of
attacked by ticks they kind of all just
went towards
yeah yeah and I'm completely fine
I've ever people my family that have
contracted lines it says god Greg was
when he worked on a paper he did a kind
of year-long investigation into just how
much Lyme disease can affect the body
and oh yeah that's it yeah he's been
actually very very afraid of it and Jen
and I Canadian British person just like
yeah I'm just gonna go on a hike it's
gonna be great man and then Greg's like
no-one ever doing this again go from
your phone's yeah okay so I think
everyone's pretty much in position this
lad he's you know one hit he's having it
he's having a good time but I think
we're pretty much ready let's go wasn't
there a guy in a red robe over there I
think on the next turn I'm gonna I'm
gonna make the move and yeah we'll try
go for it here he comes
you just wait I'm gonna swing this big
Jim let's try and take some pop pop
shots can I do that mmm
not really how can she hit me from there
you know what let's just bring it one in
we have another $10 donation from Matt
Hawking thank you so much once again
Matt's
support and while Lucy is moving some
people I will just point out again that
we are raising money for both black
lives matter global network and for
director Lee for Cove at 19 the links
are in the description but right Oh God
sway and Union both of burrows bit ly
links and tell me if you so choose we
would very much appreciate the donations
anything helps and otherwise thank you
so much for watching and supporting us
Oh Kimmy boying the chat says stream so
wholesome
nice to just chat and play games yeah
yeah here we go yeah otherwise I feel
like if I'd left him he would have a
hundred percent like I would have got
it'll go down to this he would have come
up behind me and just absolutely
obliterate me in the last time so gotta
look for quad that's perfect
so okay let's see what's gonna happen
here because I'm showing a crab man
tacacs it's the crow
like that's Lin Hart's gonna take a nap
oh it hurt all right sure is there oh
okay you and Leonard oh no oh no we get
four hits another one another one coming
okay okay my heels Oh No okay let's we
haven't used physic yet so you're all
right all right come on in Marianne girl
come join the party
alright so if you are not where I'd like
you to be health-wise so I'm just gonna
leave you I was gonna say Dee have a
whole Nuri
yes I do but I can I can rewind right
yeah oh no that's it anyway
oh you got a lance of Rowan on sylvain
okay oh I can change that no why not I
don't I do it
oh that's all what's gonna do
oh no bad then I don't because I what
dance
yep get all those points go up I love it
that's a nice one as far as the black
alright not the end are you missing
somebody
oh no what are we missing
we're I have to stand in the middle or
something no no no you just there's
someone that you haven't killed unless
you need to take this squares know who
else is out there
Oh oh my god are you kidding what ladies
what are you doing back there the whole
time
oh my god I thought Mercedes you cowards
okay slowly making the way downtown back
we go and I'll kill you
[Laughter]
that sucks okay well you know enemy
phase let me guess she's not gonna do
anything yeah my god okay alright who's
got some range on them
oh and doesn't help these boys like here
this is
you know what it's fine it means we get
to revel in the victory a little bit
longer she's not gonna last long
absolutely no she's gonna get squeezed
get her over there
yeah
see if this was Final Fantasy Tactics
she'd be actively running away from you
and you pull your hair out to the next
eight turns tactics on mobile because
it's one of those games that I feel like
I should believe you can play war the
Lions on mobile but I'm not sure all
right
they just have an anniversary Oh fancy
tactics uh it did and I think they
released the soundtracks on Spotify
guys did for it might have been like
four months ago I lost all sense of time
I don't know all right Matthew Hawking
says just give up and let me say DS a
win yeah no you did it Mercedes if you
want Messi win it would indeed be a
messy win in our anniversary's calendar
we have Final Fantasy Tactics
anniversary tomorrow but I don't know if
that is the Japanese release or the
Western release I don't know that's one
thing for Orson who made that calendar I
I want to ask now doing 20th 1997 is
what it says
North America was indeed January so
tomorrow is the Japanese release
anniversary and then the four months ago
six months ago I guess was all right she
can hit me from here so let's let's get
her in let's start this ooh hello
what's silencer so she can't get me
oh mercy please
question from chat from Tom Brown out of
all the announced games Sony Microsoft
EA what's your top upcoming game well
what about you guys what is it sorry but
my job if you can hear that by the way
it's that Benjen Lucy it's both of them
we have a lot when we do the podcast
sometimes Callie will refer to Lucy and
I think it's me but it's actually just
the dog and it alone it's surprising the
number of situations in which you could
get confused the record I aimed the dog
before I had any friends named Lucy it
was - I'm Lucy and it's confusing anyway
question it upcoming game yeah let's do
this were you excited about I'm really
excited about cyberpunk obviously sad
that it's been delayed but like at the
same time I think delays are ultimately
a good thing I you know I'd rather they
not rush it I'd rather they spent all
the amount of time on it that they want
to and that they're able to and honestly
I was probably going to get it on
next-gen anyway so it would have been a
kind of strange situation if I bought it
for like Xbox one or ps4 and then I had
to wait a couple months and then play it
again I think I think there is like
cross save between the two but I think
I'm gonna start it on one platform I'd
rather start it on the platform I'm
gonna see it through with so I'm really
excited about cyberpunk I happen to us
and after this that's gonna be my way
afternoon is making myself sad yeah I'm
uh I'm actually evident like really
really busy over the last couple weeks
so I haven't kept up a lot with some of
the releases but the one thing that I
did see I was a huge huge fan of the old
Star Wars flight Sims the original
x-wing and TIE fighter excellent vs. TIE
fighter x-wing Alliance so and I haven't
had a chance to even look at the trailer
yet I only saw I saw like the
announcement graphic it didn't I don't
even think it showed any gameplay
footage but I'm really interested to see
what'd they do with that if it's if it's
gonna be like if it's gonna be just kind
of like a spiritual successor or if it's
gonna be
I need a joystick and a PC to play this
because I remember like I bought a
joystick specifically for that game and
had so much fun playing that game it
looks really cool you can play the whole
thing in VR they were saying at the
announcement oh man that's awesome and
all of the UI is like built into the
cockpit itself there's no floating you
know oh look at this good did it kill
them all killed more uh defeat more
enemies but also MVP there you go yeah
but it was really cool they have a like
a little briefing room so you can meet
up with your squad mates before you take
on fights oh my god
I have literal goosebumps listening to
describe this game not we're like they
were very formative for me I think
it just looks like I know just cuz I I
I'm less excited about the VR cuz I get
really terrible motion sickness okay
yeah I think in the Frostbite engine
whenever ever played by Alfred the
x-wing vs. TIE fighter missions have
always been my favorite and so I 100%
just down for a whole game of that
there's a single-player story line you
can play both like rebel and Imperial
yep I was always loved to play the
Imperial I was always playing Imperial
craft whenever I could choose yeah I'm
really excited about that
cally over you I'm really intrigued by
death loop really really got to know
more about that and I'll cheat a little
and I'll say new Pokemon snap yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be an exciting one
we talked about this on GameSpot after
dark this week just Pokemon snap
memories I'm interested to see they what
they do with it because it's been 20
years it's been more than 20 years a
long time yeah it's a weird cuz I don't
get to look forward to games very often
because I'm so focused on what I'm
playing so you know I just finished the
last of us review and so I've been very
head down in the Last of Us now I'm
moving on to the Pokemon DLC so me
sometimes I don't even have like time to
get excited about things which is why I
really like III cuz it's like it can be
a time to get excited about stuff the
the thing that I was sad about the most
is no Mass Effect remaster announced
during EA play really broke my heart
yeah chat lucky bringing up Assassin's
Creed Valhalla I'm behind I still
haven't played Odyssey yet I finished
origins maybe like eight months ago and
I think I just think I ordered Odyssey
I'm excited to play it I loved Cassandra
her character and Odyssey and I loved
all the changes that they made to
gameplay like I think in origins it was
a little like they were finding their
feet with that new combat style and then
an artist you nailed it
the thing about Odyssey for me is that
it's overwhelmingly huge there were yeah
in it that like they just keep adding
DLC and they keep adding like new level
caps and so it's like a never-ending
game which as someone who like really
appreciates a story it's kind of
terrifying to open up and seeing how
many quests you can have AC games have
gotten overwhelming that way for sure
like ever since even like Black Flag it
started to feel like old man is a lot to
do there is a lot to do I'm really quick
we have a $10 donation to black lives
matter from M Gore thank you so much
yeah there's a lot to be excited about I
am very excited for a cyberpunk but like
obviously that was your answer Lucy so I
had to come up with a new one but I do
want to put I really I've been really
out of the loop over the last couple
weeks the solar was gone like they just
like announced announced announced evil
8 very say you all worked hard okay
we're like I don't know it's over 50
games announced during gorilla
collective and the PC game show and that
was like so hard to keep up I was I'm
still catching up with those because I
have to put together a releases calendar
for the reviews that we want to do so
I'm still kind of like I'm trying to
figure part like Oh what was that one oh
that was the the arcane one oh yeah
raphaël colantonio um a lot of really
interesting stuff I think I I love as
well and it's like obviously e3 is not
happening but we have all of these
different events now that publishers can
just kind of I don't know it feels like
everything being a bit more spread out
means more things get more time to
Shyne rather than just you know the big
hit is from the Sony conference or the
Microsoft conference everyone gets their
own little time yeah it's it's hard I
guess for that like to compete for time
I'm gonna make there's so much great
content it's it's hard to shine you're
right hmm
let's do here we go a couple more dear
Abbey's cuz I've got some movie like
we've got about 20 minutes left of the
stream so let's kind of blast through
some of these and get some good like I'm
at me so this is from golden sorry 1
Dear Abby I've just finished my school
quarter and I'm now on summer break but
with me being so focused on school work
and being hunched over my desk I've
realized I've accumulated a lot of back
pain what's a dough to do sincerely
breaking back dough I think probably one
of the things you're experiencing is
that you're trying to become a bipedal
creature that may be one of the reasons
why your your back is hurting if you're
a deer you really need to be using all
four of your limbs to walk and like the
whole stand-up desk phenomenon don't do
that you need you need a quadrupedal
desk I don't know if they sell them if
they don't then this could be sort of
like a million dollar idea for you but I
think the most important thing for you
to do is stop walking like a biped and I
can get back down to your dear roots and
walk like a normal deer I think that
back pain is gonna go away how would a
desk for deer work
I think poorly it was I don't think I
don't think it would I don't think oh no
like there's dog food bowl like little
they make little desks for like bigger
dogs so the dog dude is like up at their
level kind of like that that's how I'm
picturing it like a hole dug in the
ground with four holes four legs and
then just like a big hole for the face
and so you just kind of like like a
massage table but is it yeah it sounds
like a spa like a deer spa going on
there is a sauna in this game so it's a
deer spa happening this is a great one
from kawaii
it's Dear Abby I have finals next week
and I'm worrying about passing my
classes how do I need to become how do I
calm down without getting anxious even
though I have to study before I take the
final exam how can I get my stress to
stop I need support free from it I need
support for a dear that it helps me to
calm down without getting stressed
signed worry okay
so kawaii cheez-its that's a lot if
you're studying if you're studying for
your test and I think Hawaii I think
people are kawaii is hearing impaired so
I think my mods are typing out what I
say I'll try to talk slowly
thanks mods if you're studying for a
test and you're getting worried from a
dear perspective I think probably you
shouldn't be taking tests I think that
you know the only test that you should
be taking is one in in being peaceful in
a meadow which you should just pass by
by being a deer I think you're I think
you're okay there the I think it's let's
let's think here I'll give my mods time
to catch up I see them typing you're
awesome is awesome
[Music]
so to give real to give real advice I'll
switch into real advice mode make sure
you're breaking it into small consumable
chunks for studying don't try to do
everything at once I use the when I talk
about multitasking I give people advice
on multitasking and productivity I talk
about how computers work computers don't
do multiple things at the same time they
use deferred procedure calls where
they're rapidly sweeping through lots of
different things with pinpoint focus so
if you're studying for your tests try to
focus on like one very small bite-sized
chunk and once you get that move on
don't try to do multiple things at once
that's that's it I think you're gonna be
fine you're I know you're a smart person
and you've probably been studying
throughout the semester really most of
the time when it's like my test coming
up what should I do
you should have been paying attention in
the whole semester but you've probably
been paying attention the whole semester
so don't worry too much
good luck yeah good luck I think as well
meditation is very very helpful yeah
it's way you can get stressed and I am a
huge proponent of it just taking five
minutes for yourself to try and not take
your mind off it and just breathe and
think about a calm deer in a meadow yeah
couple times a day
hopefully tackling Epling tests and and
multiple classes and tests at once it is
kind of like a fire emblem battle you
really have to do one action at a time
you try to think about everything all at
once they're going to get a little bit
overwhelmed that was definitely my
biggest struggle in school was I would
think about everything I had to do and
get stressed out and then I wouldn't
even know where to begin and the answer
to that is just to start somewhere you
have to start somewhere so start with
just one class go from there
because otherwise you can really easily
get yourself overwhelmed but you can do
it and you know you can do it tim says
sleep is super important when studying
don't burn the midnight oil too much
you've got to get shut-eye too
process all the information that you've
learned that's a really good tip and if
you get stressed and you're lying awake
thinking about things make a list of the
things you have to do tomorrow so you're
not going over in your head thinking oh
I've got to remember to do this you've
run it down and that can and like
hopefully that can give some release and
to celebrate some good advice we have a
twenty dollar anonymous donation to
Direct Relief thank you so much thank
you had a Nima so Gerald just what I
love Geralt of Rivia so much Tom Brown
says this is like gamespot ASMR
having a chill time verdict am I talking
too close to the microphone is that like
have you ever considered doing ASMR so I
have not just considered but I have
accomplished it I'm I'm one of them the
male leads in a tome a game called mr.
love Queen's choice which is just a
great name in and of itself yeah and
they have several ASMR they call them
close to you sessions they are the most
awkward thing I probably have ever done
in voiceover but it's also really fun
it's just it's very strange to talk like
quarter of an inch away from a
microphone about one of them is one of
them is I could take these antlers off
one of them is uh counting sheep trying
to help someone fall asleep it's like
the character is like the carriages name
is Gavin so Gavin is trying to help the
heroine all asleep so like it's just I
was in a room and I counted to a hundred
at about this level it's like just
really really and it's just so like yeah
so yes I've done ASMR and it is it is a
wild strange experience a you know ohto
ball games incorporating ASMR is truly
inspired
I love ya and the fans really like it
like people get really excited when a
new ASMR section comes out
try to remember there was a there was an
anime about it was pillow boys anime and
the Japanese I think was Makoto done she
um
let me see if that's right but it was
about like it was really short episodes
just every episode was just a different
kind of boy trying to get you to go to
sleep oh yeah interesting let me see if
I I don't think I got that name exactly
right but it's I see
she really weird it was so weird I would
not like recommend it but I feel like a
unique experience
it wasn't unique experience and I feel
like this it's a couple years old now so
I feel like the the otome a kind of
service games if we will um I've evolved
from that sure yes Joe is there a name
for when you're kind of doing anime when
you have to do that or the kind of the
anime reacts her name for that and like
I know you just said that doing ASMR
felt awkward
is there anything when you're doing
voiceover that feels awkward or like
just I guess not natural to do I made a
YouTube video about this and it was a it
was a joke sketch between two people
both of whom were played by me and to
her anime director and an actor in the
booth and it's it's been my most
successful YouTube video like people in
Taiwan or writing news articles about it
exactly about what you're talking about
and and yeah at first you know I can see
it being really awkward if you got into
anime dubbing and you had never seen
anime yeah and that's kind of the idea
of what I was I'm pointing the booth
because I filmed half of my half of
myself in the booth and it was like the
directors like yeah okay the next noise
I need from you is a nod and I'm like
I'm sorry nod to make noise do not make
noise people make noises when they nod
is that kind of a thing and then like
I'll be like yeah this is a really
really important one was like yeah I
need I need a hesitation reaction and
it's like well there's there's three
dots on the page
okay those three dots make noise in
Japanese yeah
to say it it's like so yeah people
making has a like huh it's something you
get used to it was easy to step into
having like been an anime fan growing up
and I can really imagine like how weird
it would be and have no context for
anime and then be asked to act in that
very specific style I love that so much
because I know exactly what nodding hard
sounds like in anime yeah like I can
really really hear that is like if you
if you've never watched it like that's
just not something you encounter like I
love that feature though being able to
see the chat log helps me so much I'll
be like wait what I wasn't paying
attention
son of five has it too and I've read
recently I'm going through royal the
chat has gone very hard on dear phone's
right now oh good
big proponent of that so now I says what
do you call a deer with no eyes and no
legs oh wait no no ham no I says what do
you call a deer with no eyes no idea no
idea what you call a deer with no eyes
and no legs still no idea okay uh tom
says what do you call cute deer I don't
know Cady's he says the jokes oh dear
what do you call a popular deer where
did you find that picture it was in a
library I don't know dear friend a dear
friend I think there was so many these
what KDC what's India's favorite bread
under breath what are your bread
sourdough like mine okay Ordo yeah
like I am surprised that without many
did just what okay this is a very good
Dear Abby this is from Baba Torre I'll
let you get on there Dear Abby lately
I've been listening to original Disney
Channel songs with another dear in Greg
chance server and felt nostalgic
especially since I've moved on to gaming
in these past few years
what's a dear to do since she's feeling
this way signed a nostalgic dear you
could go back and play some really old
games go back and play The Lion King
game on on Genesis right a game hard
you're gonna spend ten minutes and then
you can be like that's fine I'm done
with nostalgia okay okay I can't get
simple just friggin whatever this is I'm
not I'm not doing it anymore so yeah
that's how you cure your nostalgia you
go play the Lion King game for five
minutes and you'll never want a game
again or you play something or Kingdom
Hearts well you get like there you go
brand-new you know final fantasy ask mix
of the classic Disney and they have all
the music so you know it sounds pretty
good to me
yeah originally do it was a way I could
like give you my antlers but you're kind
of below me in the screen one although
they're saying original Disney Channel
songs so if you're meaning stuff like
Hannah Montana and Camp Rock and High
School Musical can't help you there yeah
I'm out yeah that's I do tap out there
sorry yeah oh this is a great is there a
Hannah Montana game really quickly do we
know if there's there's a cory in the
house game if there's not a Hannah
Montana game I think I have to make it
there's no absolute yeah
I wondered is it like a rhythm action it
must be a rhythm actions I don't like a
Hatsune Miku Project Diva megamix but
cory in the house difficulty the game
it's called Hannah Montana the movie the
game I love stuff like that doesn't only
a game that
like Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part 1 the movie the game
there's one I think it's the longest
title and video games I think it's a
Power Rangers game I think it's Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers the movie the game I think
something like that we're about to get
about to get spongebob squarepants
battle for bikini bottom rehydrated
another very long title be king of kids
channels I mean Kingdom Hearts 2 point
was it Kingdom Hearts two point eight HD
every drop passage was my favorite
they're all like Kingdom Hearts titles
are an art in and of themselves no it's
like the Jackson Pollock of video game
titles just throwing everything at the
wall disease yeah it's all I thought you
were the the Kingdom Hearts they they
had a new I think it's a new mobile game
they were doing and he tooi it out what
do you think the game is cold and I was
like well no one's gonna get this way to
go who's gonna guess that I was about to
say we should would be closer to a tea
party oh oh yeah wait am I gonna do a
green divorce poop perfect they're doing
great
oh dang we were eight dear Jen from
currents the drag car and the dragon
okay Dear Abby I am madly in love with
gatekeeper but the only time he ever
speaks to me is when he has nothing to
report
what am I doing wrong what's a dear to
do whoa okay look get my chat gets so
mad at me when I hate on gatekeeper
because everybody loves him so much but
look your trust in the opinion of a guy
I'm not saying any to pick better men
I'm saying that his name is gatekeeper
in the entire time of Fire Emblem three
houses he had to two or three
opportunities was the three
opportunities where somebody like he had
the opportunity to actually keep the
gate and he blew it three times he
biffed it he biffed it three times okay
I'm not saying that he's not a cheery
nice young man I'm saying that maybe if
he was like yeah I'm gonna change my
gatekeeper to a great marriage person
don't do that yeah okay I'm just saying
the way the way you do one thing is the
way you do everything and he does not
keep gates it is such a good point sage
advice Kyle's gonna stab me you gotta
you gotta have standards look I don't
even want to look at my chat right now
like everyone oh god yeah everyone's
like how dare you shut your mouth I'm
being threatened with baguettes dream I
know I'm obsessed with it it reminds me
of Angelina Jolie at the Oscars that one
yeah well yeah I get that the big slit
up the side of the dress and and
everyone just kind of post the leg out
for a while um okay I think we should
end this dream on one on one last Dear
Abby question baby mm let me battle beer
I like this one so from Guerra sort
auntie Abbey recently I as a deer have
been training on an island that is
supposedly of Alma however when I got
there there was no armor to be found all
that was there was a little bear cub
doing kung fu should I help said cub
with its training again so specific this
is a really specific and at first I
thought it was an animal crossing
reference
I'm sorry I'm just a Pokemon reference I
don't know I'll be honest with you I
think you should get the hell out of
there I think this sounds I think this
sounds like I think you're I think
someone's trying to trick you into being
a party to what sounds like a
cockfighting ring like you know you
don't want to be involved in animal
combat okay so you should probably get
off that Island before before you get
involved in some illicit activity that
may or may not be considered animal
abuse
yeah that's your best bet you run away
you run away but you're a very good at
thankfully unless it was like a Kung Fu
Panda type situation when okay just
training yeah if there are dumplings
involves maybe stick around for lunch
there I can confirm there is soup
involved and and it is a no there's more
to it I would say stick with it I would
say that this this cub got he's got some
moves dojo
there's a man they mustard Lane named
honey together they make honey and
mustard very good very good I like that
a lot a lot of food stuff going on oh
yeah there might be a good snack in it
for you is what I'm saying one of my
chat numbers it says Joe is salty
because he doesn't understand he didn't
understand how to play pokemon look okay
it just wasn't it was just wasn't like
my game okay just because I couldn't
catch anything whatever I'm not salty
it's fine I understand I'm terrible at
Pokemon I feel like even I I kind of
went back to Pokemon right a few years
ago and I was like how the hell did I do
this as a child yeah all the way through
as a kid yep um well we are pretty much
out of time Joe thank you so much for
joining us thank you for having me to
give some advice guide me through that
big battle which we completely trounced
everyone in um
yes - and thank you to everyone in the
chat who's been sharing dear puns asking
for advice and obviously donating links
are still gonna be active I think for
like three or so weeks and next week we
have a bunch more cool streams we are
gonna be playing Red Dead - we've got
the last podcast and the left are team
yeah it games but universe are doing and
team and quiz we've got a tour of sky
bolivian we've got tons of stuff so come
on join in the fun please give
generously Joe any final words No thank
you guys for what you're doing this is
awesome I hope the rest of the cherry
streams go great thank you so much thank
you guys bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]